i 100 think marriage is a good thing i
don't think marriage is a bad thing but
i believe the legal stuff that comes
with marriage is i cannot stand up by
that whatsoever when you have child
support alimony
courts department of uh family and
services we have all this
government intervention
getting involved in your life and
literally ruining you
that's that when i see the risk of
marriage versus no marriage that's when
i'm like okay like that i can't i can't
i can't just usher people into the
[ __ ] slaughterhouse you know what i
mean
what do you think john
yeah i'm i'm
i'm i'm like as a divorcee
yeah i mean i like the idea of being
married i like growing up in a family
where we're all together um
but yeah like
even before i got married that that's
what i was pushing towards because like
before
you know
i went to college i was all about oh i
want to find the love of my life get
married have kids
and then you know red college kind of
red pilled me a little bit in the sense
that i was like you know marriage is
stupid why get married
you can have girlfriends that have kids
without being married i'm just gonna do
that and then when i met my my uh ex
you know i changed my mind
and the sex was good so i uh i i left
from that and then i tried to push her
for a long time not to get married and i
wanted kids and she held that hostage
for me she's like well i can't you know
my parents will lose their mind if i
have kids without being married first so
you have to marry me before we have kids
that's so weird because she was the one
that divorced you too right so it's like
you know
i will i will give you children if you
marry me and then all of a sudden you're
like okay fine you capitulate you get
married and she's like i'm out where
they're right marriage had no meaning
whatsoever john were there red flags
that you ignored or you didn't you
weren't aware of now that you're red
pilled and you're like looking back
yes well i mean the whole you know when
they show you who they are believe them
type of thing
there's a lot of oh she's just saying
whatever like she said a lot like i
don't want kids i don't want to be a i
don't want to be a mom i don't be a wife
you know if they if they say that if if
they give you the
uh
impression that
children are a burden
rather than something they're going to
it's going to be awesome like if it's
not in their mindset it's like i can't
wait kids are so cool like it's going to
be awesome to have kids if they have it
in their mindset like oh man i have to
give up and sacrifice so much to have a
kid like if they're talking about
sacrifice through having children then
then that's a red flag because they're
not they're not really there they don't
want to do it and they're probably not
going to be good mothers and they're
going to be one of those women that use
the children as a status symbol but they
don't actually raise them so that and
that's one of the things you said
earlier rich was like
they won't have the mother around you
know if you'd have a surrogate but like
i don't see a lot of these mothers
around as it is being mothers yeah you
know because they pop the kid out and
then they have a full-time nanny who who
feeds the kid right you know the breast
milk or the formula and then they put
him in the preschool and then the aka
daycare and they're not spending any
time with the kids so
like i i would think there's a large
that's why there's so many guys who are
messed up there's a lot of these women
aren't even mothers
you know they disdain their child
they've been brainwashed and thinking
that it's a burden and it's a sacrifice
to to raise a child and they don't spend
any time with them you know i i was
pushed into spending twenty thousand
dollars a year for preschool
well while my ex wasn't even working at
the time and i was uh yes you know i
only needed three hours of support where
i wasn't watching the kid that's all i
needed per day was three hours because
that was my training and i needed a
little bit of time to rest afterwards
and
like that was still you know no good no
they have to go to this super expensive
private school
and end up costing us 60 grand well i
could have put that money into
into you know cryptocurrency or
something at the time it's like 2014
when it was under a thousand dollars
and
it's just a lot of the attitude
for those women is just you know dude
you're cutting the core of it you see
what i mean though like marriage
had no like a difference on any of
john's [ __ ] there completely tangential
so everybody talking about they want to
get married i don't think they want to
get married i think they have an image
in their head of what that marriage
entails and that's what they want but
they aren't able to take some kind of
finish line for a lot of people yeah
it's interesting because i mean like the
comparison that he made was between
marriage and starting a business and his
argument was you know if you if you go
online
and
you're looking for information on
starting a business and you're barraged
by videos on how risky it is
uh the taxation the hours government
regulations employee issues how you're
gonna get ripped off blah blah blah but
it's like
there's no scenario
it's like apples and oranges okay like
in
a marriage contract the woman is reward
and if you don't understand guys like
get my book off amazon okay read it
there's an entire chapter on why smart
men don't marry anymore um
the the concept of of marriage cannot be
compared to the concept of starting a
business because in a marriage a woman
is rewarded richly for for breaking that
contract
okay there's a lot of things that happen
which i don't have 45 minutes to explain
right now but there's a lot of things
that happen where she's going to be
rewarded originally for breaking like
there's no scenario in which a business
partner a employee a customer is
rewarded for screwing you over it only
exists in a marriage contract
so
i mean you got to look at the reality of
it all it's it's it's like okay step
back a little bit farther from the
forest or maybe step a little closer to
the forest to see it more for the trees
and the bushes and the berries and the
squirrels and that sort of stuff if you
know what i mean
you